el tipo de solvente usado puede tener un
gran efecto en una reacción si se lleva
a cabo por la vía del mecanismo sn 1 o
sn 2
veamos primero a los solventes polares
prácticos los solventes polares
prácticos favorecen los mecanismos sn 1
aquí tenemos el ejemplo de un solvente
polar práctico el agua
sabemos que el oxígeno tiene una carga
parcial negativa y que el hidrógeno
tiene una carga parcial positiva debido
a las diferencias de electro negatividad
este protón está ligado a un átomo
electro negativo que es el oxígeno eso
significa que es relativamente fácil que
el agua donde un protón al estar en
solución si el agua dona un protón nos
quedaría 1 h - el a nyon hidróxido así
que el agua es un solvente polar
si ahora ponemos un grupo al kilo de
este lado
r o h es un alcohol los alcoholes
también son clasificados como solventes
polares prácticos porque este protón
está unido a un átomo electrón negativo
así que los alcoholes pueden donar
protones otro ejemplo es el ácido
carboxílicos lo dibujaré por aquí
nuevamente tenemos un protón unido a un
átomo electrón negativo verdad así que
podrá ser donado en solución entonces
estos son nuestros solventes polares
prácticos que favorecen las reacciones
sn 1
veamos un ejemplo del mecanismo sn 1 y
como es favorecido por un solvente polar
pro tico empecemos con una luro del kilo
por aquí
y tenemos algunos grupos cr unidos al
carbono también tenemos un bromo unido
al carbono ahí está el primer paso en un
mecanismo sn 1 es la disociación
entonces este par de electrones será con
el bromo quitándole un enlace al carbono
se formará un kart vocaciòn dibujemos lo
que resulta
este carbono está unido a los tres
grupos r
y tiene una carga formal positiva el
bromo ahora tiene otro par de electrones
libres lo que le da una carga formal
negativa digamos que para este caso
nuestro solvente polar pro tico es el
agua sabemos que el oxígeno tiene una
carga parcial negativa y que las cargas
opuestas se atraen entonces el oxígeno
que tiene una carga parcial negativa se
sentirá atraído al carbó catión este par
de electrones libres atacará al carbono
que está cargado positivamente la
atracción de las cargas opuestas ayude a
que el carbó catión se estabilice
recuerden que entre más estable sea el
carbó catión más fácil será el mecanismo
por la vía sn 1 además nuestro solvente
polar pro tico el agua también puede
ayudar a estabilizar el grupo saliente
porque como ya sabemos él
og no tiene una carga parcial positiva
así que habrá un poco de atracción entre
el hidrógeno con esa carga parcial
positiva y la carga negativa del grupo
saliente entonces los solventes polares
prácticos pueden actuar como ocasiones o
como aniones y como ayudan a estabilizar
al carbó catión eso favorece el
mecanismo sn 1 el segundo grupo de
solventes se llama solventes polares
apro ticos lo escribiré
volar
a práctico
un buen ejemplo de este tipo de
solventes es la acetona veamos la
estructura de la acetona
por acá dos grupos metilo unidos a ese
carbono
esta es la molécula de acetona y también
hay polaridad implícita pues el oxígeno
tiene una carga parcial negativa y el
carbono tiene una carga parcial positiva
esta molécula se considera un solvente
polar a práctico porque los protones que
tiene no están unidos directamente al
carbono así que no es una toma muy
electro negativo por eso se dice que esa
práctica significa que no toma
fácilmente sus protones incluso al estar
en solución si puede donar los pero no
será tan fácil veamos otro ejemplo de un
solvente polar apro tico tiene una
estructura similar le pondré un azufre
en lugar de un carbono
y por acá tenemos dos grupos metilo el
átomo de azufre tiene un par de
electrones libres a esta molécula se le
conoce como tm ese o que significa
dimetil sulfona sido el limite y el surf
oxido tiene resonancia le dibujaré un
corchete que creen que le dará la
resonancia a esta molécula bueno un par
de electrones de este enlace se va con
el oxígeno dibujaré como nos quedaría
ahora el azufre aún tiene su par de
electrones libres tiene a nuestros dos
grupos metilo pero ahora sólo tiene un
enlace que lo une al oxígeno ahora el
oxígeno tiene tres pares de electrones
lo que le da una carga forma negativa y
el azufre tiene una carga formal
positiva esta es la estructura de
resonancia para el tm
s o recuerden que en la realidad es más
bien un intermedio entre estas dos
estructuras pero en un momento usaré la
estructura de la derecha para
explicarles algunas cosas importantes
otro ejemplo de solventes polares apro
ticos es el tmf que significa dimetil
formamida tiene un carbón hilo y está
unido a un hidrógeno y un nitrógeno
y aquí hay dos grupos metilo
así que si dibujamos la estructura de
resonancia para el d mf podemos ver que
se parece mucho a los ejemplos
anteriores este par de electrones libres
en el nitrógeno puede formar un doble
enlace así los electrones de este enlace
se van con el oxígeno dibujaré nuestra
posible estructura de resonancia el
oxígeno al tomar otro par de electrones
ahora tiene una carga forma negativa y
con este par de electrones que se movió
para formar un doble enlace entre el
carbono y el nitrógeno ahora el
nitrógeno tiene una carga formal
positiva estas son nuestras estructuras
de resonancia para el de mf que es otro
solvente polar apro tico los solventes
polares apro ticos favorecen las
reacciones sn 2 porque aumentan la
fuerza del núcleo filo por ejemplo
digamos digamos que nuestra reacción es
una luro de alquilo con hidróxido de
sodio así que tenemos un enea más y un h
menos nuestro núcleo filo es el año en
hidróxido y un solvente polar apro tico
aumentará la fuerza núcleo física de ese
año en hidróxido les mostraré por qué
tomaré la segunda estructura de
resonancia aparente ms o si esta
estructura interactúa con el hidróxido
de sodio veamos qué sucede empecemos con
el camión de sodio aquí tenemos un
camión de sodio está cargado
positivamente y cuando la molécula tms o
en la forma de la segunda estructura de
resonancia interactúa con este camión el
oxígeno está cargado negativamente no
dibujaré toda la estructura detalle sólo
el esqueleto porque sólo me interesa la
parte
el oxígeno que está cargado
negativamente muchas moléculas del tms o
rodean al camión sodio lo van a soltar
habrá atracción entre todas esas cargas
opuestas y se dice que el cationes está
solo atado es decir que está rodeado de
solvente esto muestra que los solventes
polares apro ticos son buenos para
soltar cationes eso retira la carga
positiva del núcleo fi lo que por
supuesto le ayuda a aumentar su fuerza
núcleo física ya que estar unido
únicamente al sodio no le ayuda mucho
como núcleo filo hay otra razón por la
que los solventes polares apro ticos
favorecen al sn 2 y por la que
incrementan la fuerza núcleo física de
lannion hidróxido dibujaré la unión
hidróxido flotando por aquí está cargado
negativamente
y aparece el tms o sabemos que es la
segunda estructura de resonancia el
oxígeno está cargado negativamente y el
azufre está cargado positivamente tal
vez piensen que el azufre sol matará al
hidróxido pero debido a la dificultad
estética eso no ocurre estos grupos
metilo en el tms o evitan que elaño en
hidróxido se acerque y forme un enlace
en esa estructura de resonancia así que
los solventes polares apro ticos son
pobres para sol bat arañones es decir
que la unión hidróxido no puede crear un
enlace lo que incrementa la fuerza del
núcleo filo y cada vez que aumentamos la
fuerza del núcleo filo favorecemos una
reacción sn 2 ya que para un mecanismo
sn 2
necesitamos un núcleo filo fuerte en el
siguiente vídeo hablaremos de las
diferencias entre las reacciones s
1 y sn 2 haremos un resumen de todo lo
que hemos visto y también de lo que
aprendimos en este vídeo el efecto de
los solventes